- [Evan] "When you believe a
thing, believe it all the way.
Implicitly and
unquestionably," Walt Disney.
I was unhappy.
I started my business because I wanted
to help entrpreneurs.
I struggled so much to
get my first business
off the ground and almost gave up.
One of the worst days of my life
was when I told my
business partner, "I quit."
I was tired of putting in all this time,
and effort, and money,
and not seeing results.
I was tired of working for
less than minimum wage.
I was tired of losing respect for myself
and feeling like a total failure.
I managed to pull through, beat the odds,
and be one of the success stories.
And I wanted to share my experience
and advice with others.
Because I almost didn't make it.
I wanted to make their
path a little easier
then what I had to go through.
But I was unhappy.
I was unhappy because I started doing
all sorts of different projects.
A website, YouTube videos, radio shows,
media interviews, and so on.
But I wasn't getting people talking
about my business enough.
It seemed too scattered.
People couldn't wrap their heads around
what I did, because it
was all over the place.
I needed clarity.
I thought it was a marketing problem.
So I met with a friend, Jason,
to try to come up with a
tagline for my business.
Over the years it had gone from,
"Helping You Build the
Company of Your Dreams,"
to, Motivation and Strategies
for Entrepreneurs,"
to, "Over 20 Million Entrepreneurs
Helped and Counting."
Weak sauce.
What we came up with was,
"Hungry Entrepreneurs
"Deserve Help."
This felt better, but
still wasn't quite right.
Something was missing and I couldn't
put my finger on it.
Then Steve Jobs changed my life.
One day I stumbled upon what would become
one of my favorite YouTube
videos of all time.
It was Steve Jobs,
talking about marketing.
It hit on exactly what I was missing.
The core selling that
made Apple so successful.
It had a dramatic impact
on my business and my life.
Here's part of what Steve said.
- If you act on what Steve Jobs said,
you'll spark a movement.
This speech was given
just after Steve Jobs
returned to Apple.
In his absence, Apple had struggled.
It was a few months away from bankruptcy,
had only 4% market share,
and was losing over a
billion dollars a year.
Asking Jobs to come back
was a desperation move.
Apple had just been through
three different CEOs
and nobody could make it work.
Jobs agreed, and took his company
from life support to being the most
valuable company in the world.
It might be the single,
greatest turn around story
of all time.
It's time for your business
to start taking off too.
In this speech, Jobs outlines the basics
of core selling.
The way to do that is not to
talk about speeds and feeds.
It's not to talk about bits and megahertz.
That's feature selling.
"It's not to talk about why
we're better than Windows.
"And what we're about isn't making boxes
"for people to get their jobs done,
"although we do that well."
That's benefit selling.
Marketing is about values.
"We have to be really
clear on what we want
"them to know about us.
"Apple, at the core, it's core value
"is that we believe
that people with passion
"can change the world for the better.
"That's what we believe.
"And we believe that, in this world,
"people can change it for the better.
"And that those people who are crazy
"enough to think they
can change the world,
"are the ones that actually do."
That's core selling.
Mind blown.
I finally had some clarity.
It was time to get to work.
If you want to model Steve
Jobs' amazing results,
you need to get just as clear
about who you are and what you stand for.
Once you have clarity,
everything else falls into place.
I was frustrated that my business didn't
have enough momentum.
And I didn't have the clarity I needed
to move forward.
So I made a list, to try
to find my core value.
I started with my, "Hungry Entrepreneurs
"Deserve Help," tagline.
I wrote down ideas of how to convey
the emotion behind my work.
Something that really
got my blood pumping.
I purposely tried not to think too much.
Instead just started writing whatever
entered my mind.
Here's what I came up with.
"Hungry Entrepreneurs Deserve Help."
What I do, what I believe,
but not inspirational.
"Entrepreneurs change the world."
"Entrepreneurs are heroes."
"Celebrate Entrepreneurs."
"Rallying Cry."
"Gets your heart pumping."
"It's on you."
"Take your shot."
"Believe."
"Follow your passion."
"Overcome."
"Persevere."
"Keep going."
"Step Up."
"Don't Settle."
"Start."
I didn't love anything on the list yet.
Nothing felt quite right, yet.
So I decided to sleep on it.
If you're struggling to make a decision,
sleep on it and see how
you feel in the morning.
I felt inspired by Steve Jobs,
and was ready to act but was frustrated
that I couldn't get my clarity.
I wanted it badly but it wasn't coming.
So I slept on it.
I came back to the same
list, the next day,
and one word jumped out.
"Believe."
it was right there, in
the middle of my list.
I thought about what believe meant to me.
I came up with this.
Believe in what you're doing, passion.
Believe that you can do it, confidence.
Believe that it will work, conviction.
Finally, because I felt, "believe,"
on its' own was too simple,
I started looking for ways to add to it.
Believe you can.
Believe in the possible.
Believe more.
Believe it all.
Believe in belief.
Believe in believe.
The more I look at the list,
the more I realize that
I just like, believe.
So I decided I was going
to do this crazy thing
and rebrand my entire
business around, "believe."
It felt right, and my
life was about to change.
The one thing that hit me pretty quickly
was that this was more than just a slogan.
This was a value.
This was a personal mission statement.
This was a way of life.
"Believe," became #believe.
It started my movement.
I look back at the people that I
had hired on my team,
and the ones who were still with me
were the ones who also had
believe as a core value.
I reflected on my personal life
and realized that I'd always been
about believing but I never realized it.
I loved reading books about the little guy
who overcame the odds, to be successful.
My favorite book is, Seabiscuit.
Which is the story of
an undersized racehorse
who's victories lifted a nation
in the middle of The Great Depression.
My favorite entrepreneur is A.P. Giannini,
the founder of Bank of America.
Who made loans of as little as $25
to people who's only collateral
was the callouses on their hands.
He would lend money based on a man's face
and a signature.
My friends are about, "Believe."
The songs I like are about, "Believe."
Everything that makes me come alive,
somehow relates to, "Believe."
"Believe," isn't a
marketing slogan for me.
It's who I am.
You need to find who you are.
Then you can start making
some important decisions.